the growing gap between rich and poor
Americans is one of the biggest
challenges facing the country get this
the richest 1% controls more wealth now
than at any time in more than a
half-century and that's a concern cited
by every leading Democratic presidential
candidate and a recent bipartisan survey
found that most Americans 61% think it's
a problem but how big of a problem and
what does wealth inequality really look
like in this country we found that most
people have no idea you want to talk
about wealth inequality no all right the
topic may be everywhere on the campaign
trail you want to talk about wealth
inequality in America not so much hey
when I talk about wealth inequality Oh
another time we'll catch you later so we
got some free pie here free pie we
turned America's economic pie into a
real one this is the American Pie and
found a lot more people willing to
address a simple question who gets what
we have five plates alrighty this
represents everybody in America ok so
you've got your wealthiest 20% all the
way down to your poorest 20% and that is
the American pie the pie itself
represents about ninety eight trillion
dollars of household wealth in America
we ask people to dole it out as
accurately as possible I guess start off
with two slices on the wealthiest okay
how many pieces of the pie would you put
on the middle-class
put fool four all right that's the
middle class let's do half a piece to
the poorest like right in the middle
there yep okay perfect
so our gonna have to move some of the
wealthiest to the lower class how much
to pieces to the lower middle lower
middle class so can I show you what
reality looks like not like this
obviously unfortunately not no one was
even close so it's actually nine pieces
of pie yeah ninety percent of the wealth
is right here in the top terrible now
the upper middle class and the middle
class they share one piece so these guys
they've got about 80% of a piece they
get twenty percent of a piece and then
the lower middle class they've got point
three percent of a piece yeah they have
some crumbs there
there you go that's what they get and
the poorest they have no pie in fact
they've less than that then no pie they
have they actually have a bill for pie
the variant pie debt they owe pie people
in the poorest 20% are on average more
than six thousand dollars in debt
it's very sad yeah very sad very
depressing I grew up here
really uh-huh that was me let me show
you something else
mm-hmm so even if you just look at the
wealthiest and you go to the top 1% so
the wealthiest 1% of everybody these
people alone have not one not two not
three but four slices of pie what do you
think I want to who these people are
that we expected not at all disturbing
this election cycle Elizabeth Warren and
Bernie Sanders had promised to
redistribute the pie with a special tax
on Fortune's fifty million dollars and
up the wealthiest people in this country
will start paying their fair share and
polls show most Americans support the
idea they should be giving a lot of that
over here do you think there should be
an extra tax from the super wealthy why
not they could afford it yes they should
well it happened probably know you're
not hopeful not everyone is on board as
we found talking to people near some of
the biggest yachts at the New York Boat
Show that's against sort of the American
Wedding John Sheffield and Mark tedford
run an investment firm in Connecticut
they oppose the idea of a wealth tax via
total disaster
actually like for them to continue to
promote it because they will get elected
in that way wealth redistribution is
always popular amongst the masses who
don't have the wealth and not popular
remotes the 1% to do well it's popular
but doesn't make economic sense to me
so help me understand that because
you're acknowledging that there is some
unfairness here there's a lot of people
with not much and there's a small
fraction of people with a lot right
I guess the alternative is that we need
a socialist economy where everyone has
the same that doesn't make sense either
a lot of people who have a lot have
earned it and made it started their own
companies they've grown businesses
they've worked hard they've gotten good
degrees they've gone to school they may
have had it from opportunity than others
we just haven't done that a vote for any
Democrat in 2020 is a vote for the rise
of radical socialism and the destruction
of the American Dream the political
fight will continue I have nothing else
to offer but time I'll take it but at
our little table redistribution was a
hit if I'm going to take a piece it will
be from the excess okay
rich people five in the commercial break
will divide up not sweet potato well you
know this was better for for mixing and
removing it around on those plates but
you know I have to serve this American
Pie there's economic pie with a glass of
cold water and that is as follows a
wealth tax according to researchers at
the University of Pennsylvania might
actually slow overall economic growth
which is why those folks at the end at
the Boat Show are opposed to it I
thought it was interesting when he said
that may have an opera or having an
opportunity maybe part of the problem
and I think it's not just the
opportunity but when you point out how
hard it is to get out of poverty I mean
that's really telling it is very hard
$5,000
Americans are incredibly optimistic so
they actually overestimate how likely it
is that they're gonna go from where they
started to rich so why would they
support a wealth that the other
significant thing is that gap between
rich and poor has been growing
consistently as we go years now it has
so it looks like the playing field is
favoring one side oh I do hope Marco
Rubio is right we don't have haves and
have-nots in this country we have haves
and soon to haves
all right to see what the wealth gap
looks like in terms of real money not
just pie go to our website CBS this
morning dot-com